[Music]
Hubert but oh you can call me
eventually hubby
where are you from wow okay these shoes
they're cute yeah they're nice I feel
like James Bond are like uh so I've been
drinking a whiskey on the Rocks okay gay
people bisexual trans yeah I love
everybody you love everybody yeah I
believe in love speech
because he was he was telling me with my
friends women are insane this is why
women are crazy I'm literally older than
you and you're calling me a baby
right now yeah you woke up an hour ago I
know
well
you want to tame a drug dealer yeah
so what is a red flag with you
[Music]
okay sneako okay how how are your dates
how'd they go it was a great range thank
you Pearl I think hopefully I find some
love and it was a great variety of women
every different kind of girl in one
place different races different ideas
different levels of Haram and I I like
what do you mean different levels of
Haram oh there's some there's some these
girls are gone some of them what
happened
they're just completely recreational use
only oh
and they have no intentions of and even
their priorities like it's just really
funny what they're what they want
and it was just interesting it's fun if
it had all the same different if I had
the same type of girl the whole time
it'd be boring but it's good that
there's how did they differentiate
between London girls versus Miami girls
pretty much the same pretty much pretty
much the same just the accent is
different it's a little bit more
annoying here it's unattractive I don't
like the are you from your coffee Don
like okay but they always criticize
fresh and fit for example for having oh
you just have these Miami girls on I'm
telling you in the west there's there's
not that much variety there's Variety in
terms of like how Haram they are but
their ideology their beliefs pretty much
the same you're going to find the same
girls all over could you have found a
wife today I think so I think so I
picked four and one is wifey material
and I actually am like I'm getting
butterflies just thinking about it oh
yeah
uh so I know this is tough for you it's
not it's not at all I know this is
really hard I know you've grown
emotionally attached to all the girls
here today
um so tell me about your date with uh
Alicia girl in white Haram
so she's completely she is Haram but
she's she's like Recreation like she's
fine you see if I'm gonna pick four yeah
you need to have one of those in the
squad in my opinion okay so I made a
recreation
she's close she woke up an hour ago from
clubbing last night like who wakes up at
5 p.m and then comes and does a date and
she's drinking now
uh so she's an alcoholic she's 19. she
woke up from the club started drinking
again and it's already planning to go
out tonight hurray like and she has no
intentions to change her lifestyle for
another six years she wants to keep
clubbing until she's 25. so if she wants
to keep on having fun I'll join the
party okay okay
absolutely okay no Aisha nose ring
I like her she's a sweet girl and she's
she's very innocent and I like her I
like her personality she's uh bubbly
she's nice and she I think she's in the
perfect position where she could I don't
want to say need but she could benefit
from somebody who reprograms her a
little bit so that she can have a more
optimistic view of the of the world and
of the future because she's so
kind-hearted that if she's with the
wrong guy like she's gonna she can end
up in the wrong place so I think that if
I were to date her I could uh even if it
doesn't work out I think she'd be in a
better position than without me Jasmine
curly hair
dog recruiter here yeah
um
she just really threw me off uh by she
thought it was 35 and I told her I'm 24
and she went you're a baby and she's 23.
I'm older than her and she thinks I'm a
baby it's just stupid so yeah I mean no
she's not gonna be selected but I think
she understands why like we don't really
you know just let you know no there's no
spark there's no spark and also
butterflies there's no butterflies I
made the mistake too of talking about
her traumatized ex and all I talked we
talked so much about her ex which you
shouldn't I don't recommend anybody
doing a date but I'm just like I've been
on so many today I was just interested
in just trying to make conversation but
I framed it wrong from the jump talked
too much about that it was clearly
making her emotional so it's just you
know what she was emotional about her ex
on the date
oh wow that's a red flag yeah so I can
understand why you wouldn't pick her
yeah no I didn't need to keep on prying
but I'm just like I'm a curious I like
interviewing and quiet I'm like I was
trying to figure people out so yeah
um we also have Jessica you wrote tits
yeah titty was great uh Cruise titties
and I complimented her her boobs during
the
during the date and she was receptive
about it so she seems like fun she's a
little loud
very vibrant like big exuberant
personality which is a bit much for me
she has more personality than me she's
very
but yeah she's you know nice size
um Esther
30.
uh
not really you know I kind of bored her
already I mean I mean because we went on
two dates and she's just there wasn't no
spark yeah no spark no spark
she's pretty though
uh she left earlier your first date oh
yeah she's actually she's nice she's a
really nice girl
um I fake eliminated her I fake
eliminated her earlier in an interview
because
um she was leaving but no she was nice
she made a lot of sense she is wifey
material
comes from a good household and
everything like that she checks a lot of
the boxes yeah I like her Nazarene yeah
I wanna I wanna get her pregnant I think
that would be great for the both of us
so you found love today all right well
hopefully I I don't want to speak too
soon but I I I am in love with her so in
the out of sneako's mouth he found love
on the pregame just pearly thinks the
red pill Bachelor I did I felt I found
my red pill wife so she's more red pill
than me like it's it's really just
I know I thought you guys would get
along I like it a lot so I was I was
begging her to come from work today I'm
gonna ask her out after the show for
real I want to I want to take her out so
so
I know this is tough
um who are your final four
wifey wokey titty and Haram Haram is a
blonde girl her Haram friend can go
um I don't know they're probably gonna
want to leave together so we'll see if
they both leave whatever we can replace
it with a recruiter but yeah titty for
you know nice add variety the wokie
because I see you're good in her and
wifey because she's just a mother of my
children
okay ladies
um please leave yeah if you didn't pick
you you gotta go
thank you
okay so now we've established um
I I'm very happy that you didn't want to
disqualify me based on my authoritarian
stance on changing your gender okay can
you describe your perfect husband
perfect husband yeah um is there
something you think about a lot
to be fair yeah I do think about it but
at the same time I don't think there's a
such thing as perfect I think it's more
of an my ideal man like I would want
someone that's genuine obviously
everyone says loyal
um supportive what does loyalty mean to
you for me Loyalty means being there for
me physically mentally and emotionally
and obviously keeping me grounded and
obviously we support each other and
build each other both up not just him me
building him up or him building me up I
feel like we should do that together to
form a like strong unit and
communication should be good as well
that was a very job interview response
oh really yeah
sorry I just saw you kind of switch off
and just say oh
[Music]
no don't don't say sorry I don't
want can you visualize this person like
what
what's your Ideal Husband like what
personality wise looks wise
um personality wise I wanted to be funny
bubbly down to earth bubbly yeah like
just have good as you say you want a
girl
you want to grab his butt and you want
him to be bubbly no not bubbly like
Ben
oh
I look at the shape of your mouth it's
banter Ben
say Ben like ban ba no not bar no it's
Banta oh okay sorry describe describe
him please um
where was I good banter
um
made you're both the same height anyway
did you have to think about that no I'm
just just just making mental notes okay
um
nice eyes
what did you just say you have nice eyes
don't worry
um I'm not worried
um
what else physically
nice eyes
good about time High it doesn't really
matter
body hygiene has to be on point nice
teeth
um and has a good career and stable in
himself what type of career
and as long as he's stable and just got
everything then check his career record
he could be doing anything as long as
he's got a support system enemy stable
or everything should be fine okay pretty
like crazy requirements
all right what's your body count
huh huh wait what do you say no is it
when what do you say no you said what's
your body count my body count
um
I can count it on one hand play it that
way
oh wow that's that's great that's great
okay how have you kept it low because
respectfully girls with tattoos
usually you need a couple more hands for
the body count okay yeah but why do you
say that is that just is just is that
how it is in America or yeah oh okay
well that's American Girls two different
English but um I keep it low because I
respect myself I don't just feel like I
want to give my body to anyone or any
person like it's not it's not that don't
get me wrong I've been out on dates with
people but for me to give you my body
there has to be some type of connection
if that's not there I'm not just going
to sleep with you for the sake of
sleeping with you so how long these
people how long were you all dating all
these guys
well the ones that I have slept with
yeah yeah I was in relationships with
them I'm not just going to sleep with
someone like go on a date and sleep with
them you know so all of them are
boyfriends yeah basically basically yeah
yeah boyfriend yeah so what's the
outlier what do you mean there's one
there was one or two
it just it just didn't work from going
on all of my relationships yeah I've
been I've only had like
too long no free long-term relationships
one relationship I was in for
seven years
how old are you
okay
yeah seven years
um and obviously things just didn't work
out he kind of made mistakes did
mistakes and seven years and it it broke
you left right yeah I walked away from
it he cheated yeah
yeah so that kind of broke me down like
a lot so I had to kind of it took me
two years or two three years just to
rebuild myself back up like you were
like mentally yeah I was just like
it took you two years ago not to get out
to just rebuild myself I broke obviously
we broke up and I just wanted to focus
on myself like my career just enjoy
being alone like having me time not
worrying about all what's my partner
doing I just wanted to take time out for
myself and then obviously after that I
rebuilt my confidence and then
met people this relationship took a lot
out of you yeah you did how did you
catch him
how did I catch him into my God I just
knew something was off like
I can't explain it like when your gut's
telling you something's wrong like nine
times out of ten something which is
wrong so then how did you or you look
through his phone no I just it's just
it's long to get into basically he was
working
with my brother my brother got him a job
and then he met someone in the store and
obviously my phone was also working in
the store at the same time and then she
kind of told me oh he's messing around
with this person and she said the girl
said that she doesn't care that he's
with me and it just escalated from that
I could try to give him chances and
chances but he still kept talking to her
so I was like you know what if you're
gonna yeah if you're not gonna leave it
I'm done was she hotter than you
I don't know
I know what she looks like she's a
pretty girl I'm not gonna not gonna say
she's ugly just because she whatever
happened she's very pretty but hotter
than me I don't know for him maybe yeah
but
everyone's sees things differently like
I may look at you and say wow he's
beautiful and someone else may see you
but like no he's not my type so it just
depends on that person what would you
have done if he was like you know what
I like you
I like her less
let me keep her as a sign
there's a sign I keep praying what would
I have done if you did that yeah
I probably saw one of the left because I
don't I don't know I don't want to share
my my person and I don't want because a
lot of people say when you sleep with
people you carry their energy you take a
part of their energy and obviously the
more people you sleep if you take part
of that person with you so I don't want
to keep sleeping with him or doing stuff
with him while he's entertaining her I'd
rather just disconnect myself from that
completely and just focus on myself
so focus on yourself so what's your
career what do you do so I do freelance
modeling and I work for the NHS I do
like admin for NHS so you get take
covert shots and stuff no no not that
side of admin as in when we have like
staff I'll email them to make sure they
do training because they have to
complete certain training before they
can go and go on certain Wards if they
haven't done the training for it they
can't work on that Ward or do certain
things in that area of the hospital the
freelance modeling so like only fans
no oh not only fans like I've got an
agent but
I choose when I want to work or I can if
she if they send me like jobs I can say
if I want to do it or not so that's kind
of freelance you ever been with an
american guy me no oh
is that on your bucket list could be
yeah it could be yeah
yeah maybe have you been with the
English girl have you dated an English
girl
no
so you're interested in dating that's on
my it could be my bucket list okay
that's good let's get to know
you get some seafood
I'm thinking about it I'm trying to
remember if I've been with an English no
because I think I would remember that
accent
so you got Seafood of course yeah crab
legs yeah yeah that was you right no
that was another girl
I think that was the first one
it's fine don't worry it's no problem
but you're lucky I like seafood
otherwise it would have been a problem
okay yeah everybody likes Seafood
okay a lot of days going on yeah so all
the guys you've been with have been
British guys
as in they live here yeah but not
like white English if just if that's
what oh yeah like a Nigerian no like
Jamaican no
one was antiguing Italian one was like
you Malaysia and then you already had
ablation yeah
but he was like why are you looking so
disappointed
no it's okay but he was what
he was half Congolese and half Chinese
and then the other one was Moroccan
so I like my exotic kind of guys yeah
you know like you don't like white
British guys not saying I don't like
them I just haven't met they're goofy
looking dudes I was in the airport on
the way here and this guy uh these two
guys were extremely drunk and they're
all sunburned it's really funny seeing
like UK people because you could tell
like they were in Miami just like we
want to get some sun because they always
get burnt because they either don't use
the right SPF or they just don't use it
they just they don't belong in the Sun
and so they're covered red peeling skin
everywhere and they're clearly like like
they're like extremely drunk and they're
both standing there they're old they
look like remind me of Wallace and
Gromit okay you know those type of do
you understand what I'm saying like
um like the type of guys who sit at the
pub all day and have a pint and one guy
doesn't have shoes on
Miami on the way they come in here
he's up shoes on and they're not letting
him on the flight because he doesn't
have shoes and they're drunk and stuff
like that and I take these off because I
mean I had them in my suitcase I just I
give him and he's there and he's like
waddling in in his shoes and I'm just
bro their their outfits were they're
wearing a Hawaiian shirt and he had
cargo shirt like just like these the
pattern looks so bad at first when I saw
them like these just the blueprint
British dude but I felt bad for them and
uh it's nice of you to give
him he was very grateful uh but now like
it
we should probably should have cleaned
them because they put oh was it these
ones it was these ones yeah it was these
shoes
as long as he doesn't have like a foot
fungus you're fine I also because then I
would have it exactly but they certainly
get on the flight they didn't they
didn't get on the flight they ended up
taking your shoes back yeah that's why
I'm wearing them yeah but I felt like a
good person that moment no no it wasn't
nice for you to do that so I'm sure he
would appreciate it I probably won't
remember it but no I don't think so they
were really drunk yeah but British guys
are fun in that way they are
would you ever would you ever leave
where's your ideal place to raise a
family
um oh as in the UK yeah
um
adult place or like somewhere hot that I
like palm trees anywhere that has palm
trees I love palm trees my favorite tree
so anywhere that has palm trees Jamaica
Miami
um and what family am I on me as well
um anyway hot really because the UK
whoever is just so bipolar one minute
it's hot then it's snowing like you
so why are you still here
why am I still here that's a good
question
and the answer is I haven't met the
right person to then move away with
you wouldn't just move away in your arm
no
I would go on holiday for a couple like
six months and spend six months in
another country but to move on my own I
think I'll have to ease myself in to
another country and just get used to
that lifestyle and used to like
the culture in that country and
obviously communicate and network and
meet people before moving on my own
if that makes sense I want to just get
up and just go to another country like
that unless it's for work then that's
obviously different because you're
working but
yeah what about you
I'm still figuring that out too want to
keep traveling want to see the world
that's what I'm doing on world tour
right now okay okay see all the places
that are worthwhile and also finding the
right ones yeah that makes sense it's
not easy how many kids would you want
with the right one when you find the
right one
um
22 23.
yeah
how many can you give me
however many I'm blessed with that's how
I say it that's a lot it's a lot of work
it is a lot of work yeah a lot of work
for me too
we can manage yeah
yeah we just have to use a bud but yeah
yeah I know but um yeah I've got a
minute there thank you thank you
we'll talk soon yeah third date birthday
definitely on the ball hey welcome back
I didn't leave
how are you feeling what were your
thoughts
um this is the first day
um my thoughts are that I enjoyed our
first date he was
you did say you could fix me I could fix
you you can fix me how could you fix me
tell me how you're gonna fix me well you
heard it no I didn't hear it all I just
had that you heard it through the door
you heard on them like
um
okay I was just joking I was just you're
perfect the way you are actually now
you're lying to me no I don't think
there's a thing that I want to change
it's uh it's the kid thing that's the
main thing that I want to make you
prioritize a family again I think that's
the most important thing and also the
stuff like climate change it's just all
of that is garbage like think about it
this way
why would rich people buy beachfront
properties all over the world if climate
if the sea levels are rising why are all
the richest people why are the most
expensive cities all on the waterfront
fair enough like Bill Gates the people
especially the people that are trying to
report this idea of climate change they
all have properties right by the water
it's really that simple and the
climate's always changing pretty much if
you want to go to the next level
conspiracy level that's the next
pandemic it's going to be about climate
change it's going to try to limit how
much carbon we can emit they're going to
go check and tell us to stay inside so
that we don't mess up the environment
but so you don't think that climate
change exists it does exist it does
exist but not in the it's not destroying
the world it's not destroying the world
no recycling is a scam
all this stuff is the temperature the
polar bear is like that's just to make
us live in a constant state of fear and
that's a lot of like what woke ideology
does and
as it makes us constantly think that
there's something out there that's that
should keep us fearful because if we are
fearful then we are easily controlled if
we don't have a family then we're
unhappy and if we're unhappy then we'll
do whatever the government tells us to
do
I respect your opinion yeah I appreciate
I appreciate you being completely open
well we have to be because
I mean we're we're dating now second
date second date you know
yeah so Ari have you been in a
relationship before
I have but I've never had a long time
relationship
okay how short were the relationships my
relationships have not surpassed five
months
why do they end
um
I've been with a lot of toxic people
like manipulative
I'm not gonna go on that side on this
date type of vibe but yeah that type of
ask
um yeah my last guy that I was with he
was like 22 and 17. no I was Major okay
um but yeah so I haven't had any success
in relationships realistically I've
never had a long-term relationship I've
never felt secure in a relationship but
you're only 18. I don't know yeah so you
have time I have time 100 that's why I'm
not pressed about it and I'm just trying
to
take the experience I've got from these
relationships the past ones the not so
good ones
so I can learn happier what do you think
is the main thing you learned from those
mistakes
to not be
to not let other people's actions
determine how I feel about myself
that is the main one so like if my man
is
if he did go and cheat on me per se
um that has nothing to do with with
their self-worth and how you are of a
person yeah right because
it's got nothing to do with me you guys
are boys we're always gonna cheat
always but
a lot of the time you guys do men are
always going to want variety and even if
they're your guys in cheating there's a
very likely he's probably gonna be
watching like porn
yeah I wish I consider I mean that's
what most women do as well
do they not to the same degree not to
the same degree because you guys are
kind of just like hungry all the time
and some guys guys could be addicted to
that like they'll be watching it all the
time and that's a problem it is it
really is it messes up your head yeah
that's a normal problem that young guys
face to getting into that early 100
unrealistic expectations that it doesn't
work and they're looking at all those
weird stuff
if you if girls watch corn
we're on YouTube
a girl watch corn it's like once a week
once a month and then even then is it
really weird stuff or is it like
intimate it's like relationship and then
the boys just be going to oh like you're
watching like POV hentai just you know
GoPro lenses they're looking for
specific things girls watch like just
relationship stuff
I'm sure there's some girls out there
that are watching they're watching weird
stuff yeah but not you not me good
good
what is your body count
you keep looking at the camera
no my body count it I don't really feel
comfortable saying it but it's on one
hand like less than a hand oh okay great
thoughtless it should have been all
relationships yeah okay but a lot of
people that believe in climate change
and woke stuff and they don't think that
that matters a lot of girls like they
say I'm a girl boss I'm gonna go in oh
just like be whatever I want to be with
I necessarily don't really agree with
that I don't have a problem if that's
what you want to do like if you want to
go do that you can do that I feel like
with a lot of wrong people and I'm not
watching what other people are doing per
se but for me personally I don't enjoy
just hooking up with those different
people it doesn't feel me with no joy I
prefer to have Intimate Relationships I
like to know people mentally before I
get intimate with them at all and
I'm just really specific I physically
couldn't do something with someone if I
didn't intellectually connect with them
I physically couldn't like I would just
switch your mind off yeah it just I
can't it has to be some form of
mental like
gratification so what do you think about
your friends that do that that sleep
around all the time they can do that
it's not me that's
that's I don't really have any friends
that do that actually really yeah I have
I only have like three friends like I
don't like big circles or frenzy like
I'm really specific with who I let
around me and who I intellectually
connect with or even emotionally connect
no especially emotionally connect with
because
who bring around you as who you are so
yeah there's some of the people you
spend the most time with yeah so where
did you get these ideas about queer and
climate change and stuff like that came
from Instagram
um I don't know I
I don't know actually I just
what do you mean sorry someone must have
given you these ideas what that exists
so that like where did you learn I mean
it does exist
but who gave you the idea that it's that
the world is doomed that we shouldn't
have kids because you don't want to
bring them in this world oh I gave
myself the idea I feel like through
personal experience or some things I
just like and not so much anymore it's
just more like now I see it in a way of
like I don't want kids from what I can
see in my life right now does that make
sense
ah
so like as I'm looking at my life right
now I'm not saying that's not going to
change I'm not saying that's not gonna
change it's just right now I don't feel
like I want kids because I don't need to
have kids right now I'm just happy who I
am
that you changed before before you were
like I don't want to bring them into
this world no but I do no I I that is
why I don't want to have kids right now
but I'm saying that that's not that will
change because I might have a different
opinion tomorrow or two days later okay
do you know what I mean that's good
you're open-minded yeah
yeah what does your social media feed
look like
who are you following what are your
influences because we agree like the
people that you led into your life they
end up becoming who you are and I think
a lot of time our generation I'm a
little I'm 24 but we are on our phones
all the time I'm old no I'm saying you
said you're old and I was like old
that's where I feel that's that's six
years older that's that's quite a bit
um
our social media feeds determine what we
think a lot of time just as much as our
friends because if we're on our phones
for like average times like five six
hours a day some people are on there
like nine ten hours a day on social
media so your feed ends up really
influencing you more than a lot of your
friends or your parents or your
environment your phone is your
environment what are you who are you
following was it maybe I could look you
want can I look through your I don't
have my phone on me I don't no well tell
me
um
oh that's a hard one because I follow
quite a lot of different types of people
but I'd say my feed mostly looks like
music based I'm not gonna lie I follow a
lot of musicians like I like music I
full of musicians and people I think
look cool dress cool fashion I'm really
into fashion how people dress
um I also like follow like
I don't know actually my feed is a is
there's so much going on there I
couldn't tell you because I feel like
there's just a lot of difference we've
got a lot of celebrities no
I don't follow any celebrity everyone I
follow like I know in a sense oh really
yeah
even the musicians oh yeah some of them
not all of them of course like I follow
like obviously celebrities like I don't
know Kanye West or like oh nice
I realized when I said anything anyway
Kanye West or like um
um
uh Frank Ocean people like that I don't
know anyone around that a scaffold
obviously they don't know me and I don't
know them but like um yeah I don't know
my Instagram feeds a bit cable ticks
there's a lot of things coming but you
like to you're going out a lot I don't
know I don't go out a lot
that's all right I feel like you've
already been fixed a little bit from the
first date what it's working am I see
things differently now you are imagine
the third and the fourth
the fifth one I don't you're not fixing
me I'm just you're just getting to know
me bro okay maybe I had the wrong
assumptions from the beginning yeah
because yeah you just assumed based on
my appearance as soon as I came in he
was like the nose ring are you well I
was right you said you were yeah but
like so I mean I assume correctly okay I
guess
I could fix you
thank you that was just messing around
with you yeah
don't go anywhere that was the most
monotone greeting I've ever heard in my
life hey again hey welcome back thank
you so
what are your thoughts what are your
any play-by-plays you can tell me what
does that mean what have you been
thinking in the waiting room
um I was just thinking
did you think I was gonna pick you nine
okay because well I told you about me
going out every day I thought you wasn't
into that so I think I can convince you
like you said six more years of partying
yeah well I don't think I go with like
25 plus
like I just think that's a bit weird
you can't go what 25 minutes
that's who you said 25. yeah like 24
hours Stop maybe like 23 24 oh my God I
don't know maybe 21 or 20. 21 is when
you're just allowed you know in some
country so maybe yeah
23 I'll stop
24. maybe I can get you to stop going on
your own and we can go together oh yeah
that'd be fun you should come tonight
what's Instagram proud proud Alicia
Alessia Bell frails okay
you know the bouncer the promoter yeah
yeah we can get oh my gosh
maybe we'll see how the rest of this
thing goes
I haven't been
what time are you going
about
11. it's not one of the weird butt
plugins
oh you press the follow too
okay let's look through your Instagram
real quick
oh yeah you're what do you mean oh no
you put it public on the internet now I
look at it
you look older in your picture than you
do in real life removed I used to have
so much like filler and that makes me
look really old you removed it yeah this
picture you look like you're 27 years
old yeah and everyone says I look pretty
old because I had like so much filler
like in my lips why did you do that no
I'm not sure
um do you have a picture before you had
leftover yes it sounds like 17 that was
when I was like 16 so I didn't have it
there how do I want my one of my only
friends from London is liking your
pictures here really yeah who's that I'm
not telling you
like I'm not telling you I mean actually
I could put him he might be able to hire
you oh I'll be fool probably for what
hire you for what yeah your accent's so
strong it's hard to it's actually yeah
whole floor
we could talk about it off camera but
yeah what are your thoughts about
um where do you think that our
relationship can go
to the club
that's the only place it can go to
nah
you pay your promise yeah
yeah at what age though
no
you know you're lying when you're saying
that right are you crossing your picture
you provide for me
how much you need
what's your running
thousand something
a month
okay
is it worth it yeah no
why is it not worth it I'm signing up
for a business expense that's not worth
it no it's worth it because I'm actually
like
go from material
what makes your girlfriend material
I'm just really loyal so I'm a real
lawyer friend as well to Trinity know
the girl that came
after me
but is everything else worth it
You Think You're Gonna Keep Me satisfied
there we go
what makes you so confident
I don't know like I'm actually really
traditional deep down like
can I watch
you know yeah
on Tick Tock yeah
I'm actually really traditional use you
know even though I go out every single
day
so what makes you traditional if you go
out every single day
because I used to be a Christian so
I still believe in it
but I just I'm just struggling so once I
stop then
it's calm
you're struggling how
it's drinking I never used to drink it
was just drinking like maybe go downhill
basically
so yeah we can
see the red pill I shouldn't have this
but I want to I want to protect you I
want to Shield you from this Haram you
know what it is
yeah she got me into drinking before
that yesterday
let's go for a coffee that I was so
against drinking
and then she got me into it so I could
tell she was a terrible influence she
was the first girl that needed
so why are you friends
no no but your whole friendship is based
on degeneracy this is why women need to
be extremely careful with the friends
they keep around all you guys do is go
to the club and she didn't just like
doing other things with me so me so I'll
just end up saying okay
so you were a good Christian girl and
you were brought down by this Haram
world you know what she said when she
was talking about the husband that she
wants a drug dealer who that she's going
to convert like she said that she wants
to have children with a drug dealer
person
I mean that's your friend that's loyalty
but like is that really what you want to
be doing with it it's a nice girl she's
just
distracted
guys
she's a complete degenerate I mean
you're not that much farther I'm not
trying to say that you're you're
clubbing every day too but if you had
better influences in your life you could
see it you said you're depressed on the
first date you said that you have a
drinking problem you're 19.
let's go to church three months ago and
then I just went down there when you're
going to church were you depressed no no
I was actually bad about them we just
got like twice a week
round here actually white chocolate
so yeah
so you know what you have to do you know
it's just like
I'm just struggling
you know what you have to do yeah
you'll be okay you'll be okay
I hope so I hope someone takes you
seriously one day
the sooner you start taking yourself
seriously the sooner your husband can
take you seriously
I wouldn't I
yeah
why would anyone take you seriously if
you don't take yourself seriously yeah
but it's okay you're 19 and you seem
like you have a good hearted good person
I like you actually I think you have a
good smile and you're also extremely
attractive oh but just be careful about
the influences that you have around you
because there's a lot of people that
even though you might be loyal to them
they're not going to have your best
interests in mind they're going to want
you misery loves company
please just fix up to be honest
you'll be fine you're not it's not it's
you're 19. you think be optimistic and
the number one thing if I'm just gonna
leave you on this day like this
stop saying you're depressed
the more you think you're depressed the
more you are depressed
I remove that mindset
I don't know
you have nothing to be depressed about
oh really
so stop being depressed the worst people
in the world I don't know why I'm acting
like I'm depressed
you'll be fine come here
maybe we can go to church on Sunday
we'll come back in hello great to see
you bigger houses
so you enjoyed our first date I did it
was lovely so did I really sweet guy and
you're very funny I like your smile like
your personality what you are looking
for in life and you have a great body
thank you everybody so what was uh the
feelings like in between in the waiting
room
I was anxious because obviously I never
got to see anyone else's I don't know
how it went everyone just said they had
a lovely time with you everybody
um maturi not everybody who said they oh
it's okay I'll find out afterwards but
yeah so it was it was nice to see their
their response and then your response
and feedback um than a loud person
well it doesn't have to be a bad way no
I know I said you're very exuber you
know that you like people that's your
job it's my job and that is one thing
that um no matter what I have that side
to me and a quiet side of course so this
is who who I am so I'm glad that you've
seen her I've seen it already maybe I
wouldn't think it was loud compared to
the rest of the girls were very nervous
and everything but you're very outgoing
and you're very comfortable in your skin
and your your voice is like bouncing off
the walls compared to everyone yeah yeah
honestly I understand
so where would I uh our first date
hypothetically be outside of this
because this is our second day in real
but in the real world
ago I'm not going I would like to do
something adventurous like as in I would
like I would never be bored dating you
no you wouldn't I promise you that
um yeah I would want to do
to tips so I can see how good you are at
things so like for instance can you go
for something mini golf goat cart in
something
skating ice skating all of that are you
good at ice skating no no exactly do you
know what it's not that I would choose
something that you're good at so then we
have a competition I like competition so
what would you say you're good at out of
all these little dating Sports what
would you say I'm good at bowling
bowling I could write you in Bowling I
mean you couldn't so that would be the
good thing it's your high score oh
what's my highest score like I don't
want to Lunge you like one four
something or something or 40. yeah
what's yours
it's gonna be close oh I'm 120 130. okay
but In the Heat of the Moment I could
probably say something that's gonna make
you trip up or something like oh you
dropped your boob and then you're like
whoa where did my boo go that way no but
I have I I use the Bumpus
does that count no
no but I don't use them they just have
to be uh because I have trust issues
that if they're not up the ball could go
down the gutter so that's the whole no
no no I know I know but it just gives me
anxieties I I just need them all so as
long as we can have them up it's fine
they're going down if we're actually
going to do a competition they can't be
yet okay we'll do one game with them up
one game of them down fair enough that'd
be a great data activity and then at the
same time too what I would do is you're
standing up and you're like I'm not
doing it right and I would be like hey
let me show you how to do it properly
and then I get up behind and then I'm
grabbing your arm and you're like oh my
God you know that's I'm telling you
beforehand yeah I'd be real smooth real
smooth we go to an arcade something like
that yeah sounds good it's been a while
since I did one of those dates I usually
just uh sit down for coffee and then try
to see and
but it's been a while so I had like a
fun date yeah no I think it's important
especially early on it's all good no
matter what you both know you can eat so
and conversation always will naturally
flow so it's like it's nice to see how
someone is competitive was the last time
you went on a date
the last time I went on a date was the
about two weeks ago okay yeah how'd it
go
not that great hence why I'm here now no
it was good this is the thing I'm not
gonna lie majority I can't say that I've
been on terrible dates it's very rare
that I've gone on a bad day but it's
just the guy in the senses longevity is
you know you know when you know so it's
like as much as you had a good time but
you have a good time with your friends
in that sense
yeah what was uh what was what made you
realize that you weren't gonna click
you just don't know you really
prioritize banter yeah it has to be you
have to we have some good back and forth
we're flowing I know I see it I see it
there's a there's a spark somewhere and
yeah I feel like it comes out more when
you do activities than over a mill so
okay and how long would you make me wait
I'm not gonna lie a very long time I as
much as you would perceive me as I don't
no no no realistically I know how I am
how my answer is that I take bikini
pictures blah blah blah I didn't think
you were I know that you have a very
nice body but you don't seem like you
are easy oh okay I'm glad that's that's
crazy guy yeah I got stuff to do yeah
you know and I love that that yeah I'm
not gonna lie it would be a long time um
it would be close close to when we get
our ring on it I'm not gonna lie it's
I know I know I I'm really really
adamant now as my faith um has grown and
grown I've just been baptized and now I
know congrats thank you I know that my
next guy is my guy so it's not about
you're not cashing no more no cash no
more it's straight there the guy that is
my next guy he's the one he's my life
partner so and he can wait for me if he
if he knows that he's the one for me too
so that's how I see it so you're you're
all in I'm all in you're all in yeah
okay which is intimidating for so much
men but is it worth it it's worth it
it's worth the wait 100 how do you know
because I know
how what's your case study my case study
is that every guy that I I've only
broken up with guys so it's never I've
never been broken up with so
I know that I hold value to where they
want to they want to have me still in
that sense that's my case value they're
still texting you
some of them so it's memorable
okay so just like this conversation's
flowing yeah something else is going to
be flowing too absolutely
okay
now I'm gonna be thinking about it
so how often would you say you do how
long do you take before you all right I
wait till marriage basically really I'm
saving myself like I'm just kidding yeah
100 is this true the next girl I'm with
she has to have much oh whatever is this
real it's real I mean there's of course
there's like recreational use but they
don't count you know they're they're not
they're not even really real people so
they don't need to get in their way but
they're I'm really emotionally invested
in you have to have kids okay
interesting well that's the red light it
was great sir it was lovely too to you I
like hugging you because I'm much taller
than you yeah I'm I'm always smaller
than everyone
okay
three welcome back I gotta hug you one
more time is that what you wanted yeah
it is I actually hope the mic fails
again so we could do that
it's great to have you back
just so they kept cutting out and uh we
talked about so I asked you how you that
you'd like to go out tonight you said
you wouldn't marry me I guess you
pregnant
but it's just TV so it's different but I
do want to have um an actual
conversation and take you out for an
actual date
um you've clearly won
I told they can go bye the rest of them
no they can leave so yeah we were
talking about um the jab and how you
can't trust somebody
who's taking it because they can they're
gonna trust the government again yeah
it's hard to be with a man who has had
it because you know if they fell for
that what obviously gonna feel for in
the future like with the New World Order
are they gonna fall for that and believe
that it's climate change as well like
you have to be careful with who you
agree with okay because you have to have
the same mindset otherwise
you know you hear stories of people not
wanting to
um jab their kids and then the partner
goes and does it behind their back which
is like that's probably the worst thing
that's a divorceable offense 100 I think
it's a crime it should be a crime I
haven't heard any stories about that but
I mean I would say it's clearly the next
pandemic they're going to go and track a
carbon footprint they're going to tell
us how much we can go inside how much we
can use gas how much we can use our air
conditioning and that's going to weigh
that they're going to quarantine us so
another Fair campaign Santa is a sign up
all the societal you're using all the
same workers yeah it's uh they they
control everybody with fear
and they brainwash a lot of people into
and I've seen it with a lot of the girls
that we've been on dates that I've been
on days with today they're just like
they're clubbing all the time and
they're they're not really focused on
the future and I like that you have a
clear plan for your future and what you
want
um I was really surprised that you said
you want seven kids that's like a big
thing maybe more you think you can
handle it yeah how old are you 22. oh
yeah you can handle it yeah
and I wouldn't be opposed to it right
now I'm not doing anything like
that like I'm not partying or anything
I've never really had that in me so why
not start now
some of the better I agree I always
wanted to be a young father
but yeah this was um
I don't really find often that I click
with somebody this quickly yeah
and you said earlier when the mic cut
out that there's even a dating app for
unjapped people
you haven't used it though right I
haven't used it but I know it's there
I just like in person
um meetings more I feel like it's more
natural
yeah I think it's extremely important I
don't think if you meet somebody on an
app or something it's like Bill Gates
Mark Zuckerberg orchestrated it
is
but yeah you won and this is our third
time having this conversation scene so
we're having to force a little bit we're
having to repeat things but it still
feels
that's wrong
can I have your your contact information
all right one second yeah so I've done
that before no Snapchat though no I
don't know I'm a girl man oh my God
it's nice to hear
it's kind of not
usually nowadays
[Music]
we can cut that right we're good I won
I won she won but I won all right we're
good
I want to give you a prize or something
a price yeah I don't think I could smell
it anymore
okay okay
well can you see a way she would
uh it's pretty obvious I mean
we I think we connect well I hope we do
some of them are worse
um I want to continue talking to you I
don't feel like I'm entertaining right
now am I making you nervous no okay no
but I do want to just yeah everything
about you
there's one I'm actually similar right
now
so let's so we got some food thank you
sake sake yeah okay thanks
are you serious sometimes in the morning
like with milk and honey I'm about
eggnog
is quite done
okay yeah cool I won we win we win
[Music]